So the first game for today,
I don't think I'm fully awake yet. Well, let's have a
look here in
Pirk modern defense.
This time I didn't play jumps F3
so I can also play with F4.
Yes, black is
doing the typical
queen wing action here
Seems a bit brave to me
with the poor development here,
open the position, let
's see, there is something directly on the F-line 5
knight H6,
that was all ugly but it's still okay,
I bishop G5
can't jump F6 answers
so maybe the center
stabilize
opponent is by the way a European Championship still kitsch
from
WoW Nepal as at least online from Nepal
interesting
no wonder that somehow the flag
couldn't be identified
so the two yes and would just like to
swap the bishop with bishop H6
and then see if you are on the F line
or then maybe with Knight
G3 here what will
I get? I don't know what exactly Black
should play now. I
think he certainly has to
be careful somehow.
Yes, that's the most basic
continuation now C5,
so the question of how best to play it now is
Bishop H6 or
or can you play differently here,
I mean completely different,
how is the five, for example, the quality
sacrifice,
well
at least brave if he takes it
so he probably has to do it
brave is the wrong wrong word but
if he just lets me continue playing
then that's just a  Very thick
center and attack I then
just remove the rook,
he'll probably take it out,
yes, and then he just has a lot of the
many shetto bishops and I still have
options to add masses of figures here, okay
he has
n't taken away the quality
so now the question is where should the tower
go now
C4 is another idea from him he could
take it here too,
well maybe you can take it yourself I do
n't want to spend so much time
on it now
so yes no he attacks me two
and blocks  For now,
here's the whole story,
so Bishop F4 looks a bit tired,
I'll do H3. The idea would now be
King H1, maybe and then Knight G1
F3
is also slow, but the knight
should go to the best square here, yes he
has a lot now  Invested time to
index the exchange to me
but the bishop on the three is good because it's
not that dangerous yet so
now you can also take E5
or bishop H6 both look good.
I'll take E5
so that D4 could now be an idea
So then comes the I'll go
back to E3 in the prevents that
so yeah, he could do that the whole
time
with the idea if I move the path that
has three plays I thought but
maybe I'll do the
runner A4 runner C4  That should be good
and now I have the idea of
bishop the four and also
B5 and the pawn or to run
so where do we go now bishop F4
and with that the four game I can
swap and bishop the 6 that is
I think I've almost won
because they look very good for dinner,
of course a time problem like so often,
so now I could also take B5 for you,
and there's nothing wrong with it,
probably better than swapping the queen
with so little time,
some of us also have an attack with it
The seven, for example,
counterplay somewhere here I don't see so
forward
so yes let's go into the bondage
in here or build the statement on
going in is wrong
so what else can he try
actually nothing
not really
maybe to them
and have to clarify this here
I immediately discover rook F3
to cover it, everything discovers
each other and I can then
comfortably
clarify the situation here
without him bothering me in any way
with counterplay, so
I can just take it,
so now let's send the pawn off. The knight
is still tied up, so jumps
5  Of course it's
not about seven, it's not
like that either, yes I can take that too.
Pawn is through but I still have 10
seconds,
okay,
yes, that was a nice position
other than the opening and somehow I
think I kept it more or less
As usual, the time was
more than difficult